vous connaissez très bien ses rides fait
18 ans vous connaissez c'est vrai cyril
avant la série dames rêve avant avant
quoi avant avant alors qu'il était
pauvre
maintenant mais je dois dire que pour
ceux qui l'ont connu avant c'est le même
boulot il n'a pas bougé il n'a pas bougé
du nord est non non il n'a pas bougé une
oreille aussi drôle avant aussi fou donc
il est franchement n'a pas changé donc
j'ai passé qu'elle allie datsyuk je
raconte ça me va barder pire évidemment
va pas se mentir alors il paraît que
c'est reed a essayé de te faire croire
qu'ils ne connaissaient rien à ce sport
pour tu me dis ah oui bah ça vous avez
un peu la vie tchô jeudi alors moi
je veux dire c'est que voilà c'est un
embrouilleur et c'est vrai que celui de
l'arrivée une fois idée tu veux quoi
comme sport et moi je dois cette semaine
j'ai fait du squat chez lui fait à jack
walsh et bien ça si tu connais pas va un
petit peu mais je dirais que je te
montre alors on voit la salle de sport
ensemble on joue et c'est vrai qu'ils
jouent comme une banane quoi ah oui mais
même je lui disais il ya un problème
quand il fait gris pour jouer au tennis
quoi et vraiment excellent mais je lui
dis qu'il ya peut-être un problème de
motricité jeux je vais de même valu des
habitants mais ça a lancé la balle
points et puis il me dit ouais moi
j'arrive pas à jouer sans enjeu bien on
met 50 balles et judy h pas 35 handball
même si ça me fait plaisir en plus à
cette fois de l'argent pour noël ma
chambre ou
50 euros c'est beaucoup et c'est hélas
l'argent on sent le billet est là le
truc démarre et la hanouna c'est la
partie elle m'a écrasé j'ai pu commencer
11-5 11-2 11-3 il m'a humilié juste pour
prendre 50 balles c'est à dire que ce
qu'il a fait il avait organisé depuis le
matin ah oui je veux dire que a donc ces
derniers ces tueries repas cuisine avec
préméditation à sa tête il avait entendu
que j'ai fait du squash et les cas lui
et lily attend je vais accueillir donc
illusoire d'imaginer le vi de mener pour
cinq ans le bal boutonne journal
j'ai perdu tous mes cachets au téléphone
la wii les redoutables il apparaît que
tu connais série du tout à la culture
juive à plus forte et cyril et qu'un
jour ça tu as joué des tours
olivier parce qu'on va poser une
question par rapport à sa basse avec moi
je viens de guingamp en bretagne
j'étais pas très au fait des religions
tout ça parce que nous céder question ne
se pose pas des communautés soit ou non
quand je suis allé à paris et que j'ai
commencé à écrire donc on était que deux
dans un petit bureau c'est vrai qu'une
fois il ya une personne qui a appelé de
ses voeux des fois ça sonnait téléphone
pas souvent mais ça se et puis à
personne m'a dit oui ce serait que pour
que cyril face la barbe israël on le
voit pour sa bar mitsva moi j'avais
jamais entendu moubarak et de soie rouge
loach bon parlons c'est un enfant malade
mais c'est vrai mais je te jure j'ai été
déconnecté tu vois donc jonathan broquet
puis cyril et je vois je fais cyril
j'ai passé une association ou pas mais à
qualiac al maqtari le voir à l'hôpital
sûrement et où il me dit bon ok tu
raison de genoux ma personne et tout est
donc il s'apprête à l'appeler dire
qu'est ce cas là comme c'est cocasse est
une maladie je connaissais même pas je
vis une barbie tu vas
l'agrochimie laisse pas possible mais
c'est quoi que
les garçons c'est ça la bac mais ça
c'est pour les filles s'est adressé à 13
ans voilà belge et ça c'est à 12 ans à
tous
les garçons c'est 13 et 6 et 12 c'est
tout et ce que des bonnes nouvelles sont
plutôt des maladies comme voilà bien peu
ont bien évidemment
oui alors
j'ai entendu une anecdote assez folle à
propos d'une voiture que cyril aurait
acheté oui bah c'est vrai que j'ai il
aime bien les voitures les scandales et
les actes eux mensia des yankees et ses
quelques bas une de ses premières
voitures comme on débat là on était
toujours ensemble une gamme assez je
m'achetais une belle voiture ce que tu
veux venir avec moi je tue avec plaisir
et où on va chercher sa voiture et quand
on arrive devant donc devant la
concession descend de la voiture et à ce
moment là il ya une très jolie femme qui
arrive donc soit on descend même temps
voilà de devant et il fait coucou tout
jeudi en syrie mais lui je sentais qu'il
était un peu cher mais elle tend les
clés ai dit voilà c'est bon si tu joues
avec le patron j'ai la chercher elle est
en fait elle est partie elle a pris pour
le mécano
[Rires]
poliment on allait amener l'équipe a
lancé tu vois mes donc sachant qu'il
veut changer tout ça maintenant rompu
pour le mécano comprendre le
propriétaire de la concession bien
alors on s'est serrés d'une star du
panel formé d aller quand il pour
préparer deux pour lui son entrée dans
le top 100 oui je crois que le film
adopte et mais avant il excellait au
tennis et un jour ça a dérapé avec denis
brogniart qu'est ce qui s'est passé à
wimb en fait cyril il participe touche
parce qu'il fait toujours il participe
au tour l'un des personnalités sont là
pour l'atmosphère et puis cyril il a des
techniques
par certains ont des techniques il
s'entraîne et pier-luc voulu s'entraîner
il vient avec moi on va tu vas tu vas
essayer de perturber de niro qui joue
donc moi tu avais je suis arrivé et
pendant qu'ils jouaient moi j'avais la
mission d'être derrière deux niveaux et
je commentais tout ce qu'il faisait
c'est à dire que l'horreur pour lui tout
est allé au lit à la mairie
les trucs donne y aller salle et déroule
t'as plus rien à faire des rôles c'est
gagner il dit et ça monte ça monte ça
monte jusqu'à des trucs du style bats et
quand c'est comme ça c'est une pression
en tout à l'est de nice en fait tu fais
quoi que tu te tue les supporters
culture enfouie ils demandaient d'où je
venais quoi et puis à la fin vraiment il
a pété donc il a fait n'importe quoi et
il a perdu ouais parce qu'on joue pas
mal de nuits voyez jeu très bien mais où
il a perdu ses nerfs tu vois donc à la
fois une statue de cire et où il me fais
tu te connaître cela est tout de suite
mais je n'ai jamais vu de même
[Rires]
j'ai vu s'ériger télé voir jouer dans un
tournoi tennis pareil là il marmonne
dans sa barbe mais suffisamment fort
pour que le l'adversaire entendre
philippe sympathique avec l'adversaire
général
ils te poussent à bout de ce qu'il a
fait une fois il était déjà failli mener
4 0 5 0 il a dit à votre écoute mais la
voiture en route c'est bon j'ai bientôt
fini c'est quand même terrible le badge
était pas terminée c'est un peu c'est un
peu millions alors on rappelle également
d'un commerce de dvd clandestins au tir
il a fait beaucoup de commerces
ce commerce est variée inventaire de la
télévision un peu dans les freins et un
peu voilà il a fait les cravates en cuir
ouais journal fait les cravates il a
fallu apprendre des photocopieurs des
chaussettes en cuir aussi je crois que
ça allait je faisais dans des jus de
chaussette je vous recommande
alors c'est quoi c'est un deuxième
appareil c'était au début quand on a
commencé ensemble en fait ils recevaient
des dvd belle époque et encore les dvd 1
pour les plus jeunes c'est un truc qu'on
vient d'entendre les aider et on
recevait les dvd promotionnel des films
qu'à l'arrivée ou des balades et des
spectacles et lui il s'intéressait pas
vraiment donc avant je dis pas que je
vais je vais tout dégager du bureau de
notre petit bureau puis l'a eu une idée
à temps ces thèmes dommages se
débarrasser ça edit c'est ce qu'on va
faire on va les louer mais à qui
débarque dans un immeuble il on va
demander à l'union il vient gens que ça
intéresse donc les gens il venait et
disait voilà c'était chaud c'était 2
euros et 1 euro par jour de retard donc
il est loué donc les gens venaient
des mois je suis sympa ya un stagiaire
qui est venu je me souviens du chef
c'est lui c'est un stagiaire est tous
nés ouais t'as raison 50 centimes se
suffire
pour le reste on va le raconter qu'elle
saurait parler d'une histoire on peut
raconter c'est là vous êtes sûr de deux
films sur canal+ à minuit le samedi
qu'il aurait mis avec le son un peu fort
ah oui oui c'est vrai il a fait sa une
blague un ami à lui et je me souviens de
ça tout à fait il détaché un ami et
c'était bas donc c'était l'époque où il
y avait le film vient toujours aucun but
et c'est toujours ce film alors moi je
vais premier samedi du mois aux mêmes
monsieur connaît bien jouer
et s'amuser avant de quitter donc celle
en boîte de nuit et je crois que c'est
lui c'est le dernier à sortir a claqué
la porte il a mis le film à fond à fond
et claqué la porte il s'est barré donc
c'est qu'il ce film-là à fond pendant
une heure et demie dans l'immeuble ils
ont pété les plombs j'ai plus il avait
pété la porte ou pas les voisins ou pas
mais sur deux blagues ça c'est très bon
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]